all right everybody hear me sounds like
it alright thank you very much so I'll
get right into it all right so you guys
have probably seen slides like this
before so historically when people
describe machine learning they usually
divide it into three categories
unsupervised supervised and
reinforcement and so I think when I
started at Capital One I was probably
like some of you in the sense that I was
pretty familiar with these two but did
not know very much about reinforcement
learning and I'm hoping this will be
sort of a theme in this talk that I'm
not gonna try and sell you on
reinforcement learning I'm gonna try and
convince you that it's magical or that
can solve all your problems or anything
like that I'm more just like to convince
you that it's underappreciated
in the data science community and it is
kind of a little bit particular to
people who identify as data scientists I
think I was at ICML last spring and it
seemed like half the talks around
reinforcement learning this is a huge
huge huge area of investment in academic
research and I think we just lagged
behind a little bit and there's very
very legitimate reasons for that there
is both of these plots yanked out of
scikit-learn documentation I'm not able
to do that for reinforcement learning
and I think that in and of itself is a
big reason why this is the case it just
does not lend itself as easily to simple
packages that you can use in an
off-the-shelf kind of way but it's very
powerful so I think we should all be
trying to build such packages okay so
this is a quote that I borrowed from
Sutton and Bart Oh which is kind of
probably the most popular book on
reinforcement learning so a gazelle
caste struggles to defeat minutes after
being born half an hour later it's
running 20 miles an hour so this is kind
of like a nice metaphor for
reinforcement learning but it's actually
a little bit more than that because the
field was born out of an animal
behavioral animal behavior and
behavioral psychology back in the 50s
and the idea here is you
a gazelle does not have in its DNA
recipe for exactly which muscles to
contract at which times in order to run
but very quickly through when it's born
through sort of trial and error it can
develop a policy for running right and
this is actually a reinforcement
learning algorithm in the sense that
that gazelle was practicing alright so
some of you may have seen this in the
news in the past year so Google made
headlines with its alphago algorithm so
go is this very old game that is notable
because the sort of the space of
possible games is far larger than the
number of atoms in the universe so it's
more complex than chess in a sense and
it's very difficult to design an
algorithm that can beat a human a
skilled human player at go it was for a
long time thought not possible and then
for the first time the world champion
was beat by by this algorithm this year
so this is somebody describing that
outcome
ok so I'll get into examples and such in
a minute but let me first just try and
[Music]
define a little bit what I mean by
reinforcement learning so the easiest so
we all know what unsupervised learning
is it's clustering to a large extent so
let's compare supervised learning and
reinforcement learning so supervised
when we say supervised learning we have
this image where this we imagine a
supervisor in the case of our in the
which is our training set essentially so
it's a you can kind of query your
supervisor for examples of a similar
situation to where to the one you're in
when do you want to make a prediction
and then you will base your prediction
off of that past experience so as long
as you can supply enough examples to the
supervisor that they can sort of give
you appropriate advice you can have a
good supervised learning
reinforcement learning is what you do
when you don't have such a supervisor so
these are some terms that you'll see
coming back but the eight if you think
of the algorithm is sort of the agent
that's trying to optimize its experience
in some sense it doesn't have any
supervisor to talk to and it needs to
kind of through trial and error so to
speak learn a policy for how it can
optimize its rewards right so it has
this policy and will be continuously
updating that as it takes in new
information so this is the the same
image I showed in the first slide so let
me just make these terms a little bit
more concrete okay so you're you have
your agent the agent lives in some
environment you can think of environment
can be sort of defined as a set of
states so let's say you're you're in a
maze the state is like your position in
the maze and the environment is the
whole maze right and for any state that
you're in you have a series of actions
that you can choose from so if you're in
the maze you can go up down left to
right maybe okay so you choose an action
and then you tell the environment what
action you've taken and then the
environment moves you into the new State
so in a maze it's deterministic right
but in other cases it might be you know
well we'll see but we'll see more
examples in a second it it might be more
stochastic but as you move to a new
state you might get some reward as well
so that's the other thing that makes us
different from supervised learning is
that this is going to repeat so it's not
the same choice that you're making over
and over like you would in some
classification problem or something like
that it might be that you have a whole
series of rewards over the course of
some process and you want to optimize
the some of those rewards right and a
policy is basically a mapping from
States to actions right so in a given
state if you have your policy tells you
which action you should take and this is
what we ultimately want to we want to
learn the best policy in order
maximize our rewards okay doesn't make
sense
so let's go through a few examples we
don't have to go through all these in
detail but I just wanted to sort of list
if a number of different scenarios and
what these terms would be in that case
we already talked about mazes so robot
robots are kind of an easy to visualize
example and a lot of the research in
reinforcement learning comes out of
robotics so you can think of a robot arm
it's state is you know the the position
of its joints the actions are the
torques it can apply to those joints and
then whatever task is trying to do and
give the rewards right but a lot of us
are coming from a business context so
you know I work at a credit card company
if your environment is all of your
customers who are in default and you
have a set of actions you can take to
try and collect money from them
and each one of those actions may cost
something but you might get a reward
when you do collect then you can have
that you can try and talk about a
strategy for doing this okay marketing
we're going to talk about more - if any
of you have have used multi-armed bandit
before if not I'll just all the find
what that means but that can be thought
of as a special case of reinforcement
learning and okay call center
optimization website designer okay you
get the idea so here's some let's talk a
little
I borrowed these this list from Schulman
and abby'll part of the reason for doing
this is just to give a shout out to
these guys so that there's a course
website for this this course at Berkeley
has a lot of materials if you guys are
looking for more I recommend this and
this is from one of their slides so in a
business context reinforcement legs been
used for inventory management so this
this is again an example we have a
sequence of decisions that kind of
influence each other so you can't you
don't have a simple you know
classification model that can handle the
you just it's sort of like a it's a game
that you're playing in a sense
resource allocation and call centers
shipping considerations routing routing
shipping fleets in finance you'll see
reinforcements coming a lot up a lot and
anything that sort of sounds like a gain
which kind of makes sense right so we're
talking we're talking about finding
optimal policies or optimal strategies
so it's not surprising that that you see
this have the coming up lot in finance
so each of these examples is probably
yeah so optimizing click-through rates
choosing ads to show the users if it's
if you're making just a single decision
each time that's a multi-armed bandit
problem if you are worried about things
like ad fatigue and you want to come up
with a strategy for multiple ads to show
that's a general reinforcement learning
problem the last one is medicine so this
is I'll save that we'll come back to
that okay so here's a little bit more
detail of specific instances where this
has been applied so Yahoo labs published
this paper on their algorithm for news
article recommendation oops excuse me so
basically the actions that you're
choosing from here is a news article to
recommend to a person and you're trying
to optimize the number of times that
they click on those articles right and
they used multi-armed bandit approach
I'll explain what that means in a minute
and they found some good results with
that twenty twelve and a half percent
lift and click rate by using this as
opposed to conventional a/b testing type
approaches the Google Analytics has this
product where you know for your own
website if you want to do kind of 80
testing in a multi-armed bandit way they
offer that and there's they have some
papers explaining exactly how that works
I reckon
this there's a paper on Bayesian so
called Bayesian bandits I think about
Steven Scott has a good overview okay
we'll go we'll talk a little bit more
about this one so IBM published this
paper in 2010 the idea here is I
mentioned credit card debt collections
before this is tax collections but is
the same idea
so a lot of people owe taxes to New York
State and we need a we want to find the
optimal policy for collecting those
taxes so they're just there's actually
you can do more than just ask them to
pay there's a set of interventions that
the state of New York can take and the
question is which interventions do you
take at which times you know in order to
optimize the likelihood of collecting
from people so they they've tested this
and they expect to about a hundred
million dollar savings over three years
I have not seen what actually happened
this was published in 2010 but I think
in their back-testing they this was
their conclusion so let's look at an
idealized example of this so imagine
instead of a whole set of actions you
can take you just have one action so you
have a you have a population of people
who all only $40 and we model this as
each person will pay if you ask them
theta times but we don't know what the
distribution of theta is okay so for a
given individual you don't know how many
times you're gonna have to ask them so
in each the state is defined by how many
times you've asked them already right
and in each state you have two actions
to choose from you can either try to
collect or you can just give up and
write this one off right and then
imagine that each time you try to
collect you get a negative reward of $1
because they you have to pay your
collections agent to go out there and do
that right but if they pay up you get
$40 okay so you want to optimize the the
expected rewards for your policy okay
but as I said we don't know if they to
operate so let's just let's simulate
this
let's simulate this and imagine that the
distribution of theta actually looks
like this okay so it's got it's got two
peaks one around 20 and one around 80 so
I think what a lot of people would do
when they approach this problem is they
would just say well I breakeven point is
40 so we'll we'll try 40 times an M
we'll stop right and that's our policy
it turns out that is not the optimal
policy in this situation so this plot
here shows you the expected future
rewards as a function of state this is
the function number x you've expected
and what you can see so it goes negative
here I've cut it off at zero but it's
positive until you get to about 25 and
then it becomes negative so what what's
happening is it's worth trying to
collect until until you get to a point
where you're you've tried enough that
you're confident that they're not in
this first group right once you know
that they're it's going to cost way more
to collect then you have to get all the
way out to 80 and you will lose money in
the process of doing that so what
reinforcement learning can do is you can
never even worry about what this
distribution is you can just run your
algorithm and it will find this policy
right just by getting feedback from the
environment okay so that's the idea
you just want to this is a little bit
Matthew but I think it's worth going
into a little bit because ultimately
what reinforcement learning is doing is
finding solutions to Markov decision
processes so what a Markov decision
process but what it means to be Markov
in this context is that the the answer
the the answer for your policy the
correct action to take in a given state
only depends on that state and not how
you got there right so in the example I
just showed here's a diagram for this
Markov decision process so each state of
drawn with an S for the subscript for
how many times you tried to collect and
then in each case you you have two
options right you can keep trying or you
can give up if you give up it takes you
to the end state if you keep trying
it will either send you to the next
attempt with a probability of 1 minus
theta or it will send you to the end
state with a reward of 40 with
probability theta okay so that's that's
what this diagram looks like and this is
the problem that we're trying to solve
so here's the formal definition of sort
of what it means to be Markov but we
need to go into that too much ok there's
another example I just want to put it
because it's kind of fun so this this is
described in Sutton in Bartow as well we
kind of just ran it and I popped in
notebook just just to test things out so
the game of blackjack is the Markov
decision process so for those of you
haven't played blackjack the idea well
there's various varying versions of it
but basically the idea is you're you're
receiving cards and you want to get as
close to 21 as possible as the sum of
your cards without going over so for a
given hand that you have it doesn't
really matter what what the cards in it
are doesn't matter what choices you made
to get there it just matters what the
sum is and that is all you need to
decide whether you should take another
card or not right so this is Markov
decision process this can be solved with
a reinforcement learning algorithm and
this is what a policy looks like in this
case
so the yellow X's denotes so that this
is a state the states the state you're
in is defined by what the card the
dealer's showing and your own hand and
for a given so each box is a state and
an X means that you should hit that
that's the right choice no X means that
you should stay so this is the answer
and then the red and blue colors say are
denoting if you follow the optimal
policy if you do what you should these
are the expected rewards that you'll get
okay and reason there's two is because
it's a little bit different depending on
whether than you have an ace or not
don't worry about that if you haven't
played blackjack before those are sort
of details okay this is probably the
last mathematical slide I think well
maybe not but bear with me so the
equations that kind of describe these
Markov decision processes are called the
bellman equations and let me just
explain what this means real quick so
there's different versions of them but
in the one I've shown Q here is the
expected future rewards for a given
state and a given action that you take
right in the star subscript means that
it's the optimal one right so what this
is saying is the optimal assuming you
follow the optimal policy the expected
refew rewards for this state in action
is the next reward that you'll get comes
to the road you'll get if you transition
to the state s prime I'm weighted by the
probability of that transition plus all
of the future rewards after that so all
I want you to really note from this is
that if this is sort of known and this
reward is sort of known and this is a
constant that we choose called the
damping factor I think then what what
all this is is just a set of coupled
algebraic equations which in principle
you can just solve if you know these
transition probably
so that method is called the dynamic
programming approach so that's basically
I mean this is dynamic program is much
more general in this but basically it's
just efficient ways of solving these
complicated sets of equations in
practice it's rare that you know these
transition probabilities so like I said
we didn't know theta in the collections
example right it just had to be kind of
learned from the environment through the
process of doing this so in practice
there aren't that many interesting
problems where you can do this so one
other option is what's called the Monte
Carlo approach and with that what you do
there is basically you just play the
game a whole bunch of times and keep
track every time you're in a given state
you take a given action keep track of
what happens and then just keep a
running average of the rewards you get
and then learn q-star
that way that will converge to the right
answer for Q star it turns out you can
do a little bit better in most cases by
using what's called Q learning and this
is getting a little bit in the weeds but
it Q learning basically doesn't wait and
it doesn't wait until you've played out
an entire game in order to update its
estimates for Q star it can kind of
learn from the immediate rewards so that
it converges a little bit faster so this
was probably the state of the art as a
couple years ago and I think it's still
widely used there's another kind of new
kid on the block which is what's called
policy gradient approaches so one two
and three are all based on learning
what's called these value functions Q
this is kind of a totally different
approach where instead you well I'll
have another slide in this later but
basically instead of trying to learn Q
exactly you just try and have a model
for the policy in other words a model
for which is the best action to take and
then you iteratively improve the
parameters of that model and usually
that's done it's often when we talk
about deep reinforcement learning that
model is usually a deep neural net and
the parameters of your policy are then
the coefficients in your new neural net
and you're updating them with some
version of gradients
all right so can you press the videos
okay so so I just want to give a shout
out to this is not my own work I'm just
a fan but I want to make sure everybody
knows about open a I so open AI is this
nonprofit company that among other
things maintains this open era gym which
is a repository of test environments for
reinforcement living and the idea I
think basically is like when you look at
the recent advancements in things like
deep learning you can argue that a lot
of that was possible by having community
datasets that people could compare
algorithms on right an open era is
trying to do something similar so these
are some fun environments carpol is just
trying to so basically you can move this
cart back and forth and try trying to
balance a pole on its end this is a guy
who's trying to walk across this terrain
so you get rewards for this on how fast
you can move and this is a like
simulated physics environment where you
trying to get this fight with us as
possible this one's not a movie but this
is a snapshot from the go the game of go
a simulation of that so basically what
opening eye does is it has a whole bunch
of fun things like this as you can
probably tell they have a strong bias
towards robotics applications like I
said a lot of that research is from that
area but they're just basically it's a
standard interface where anybody can you
if you write one reinforcement learning
algorithm you can kind of in principle
run it on all of these environments and
you can compare people could compare
results on them so it's a really really
cool place to start if you want to learn
more about this you want to get involved
and justic I put this slide in just to
convince you that this isn't some random
github repo that I found this is legit
there's these are the heavy hitters that
are supporting open AI and it's got a
lot of support and a lot of really cool
people from academia or have
affiliations with open
and are contributing to it so the at
Berkeley course that I showed at
beginning with Peter bol and John
Shulman they both are working at open
air now all right okay I want talk about
multi armed bandits because I think I
heard them mentioned a few times
yesterday I think a lot of people are
familiar with them it's sort of a
semantic question whether you consider
this reinforcement learning or not I
would call it reinforcement learning
with one state so instead so basically
instead of going through a sequence of
decisions you just make one decision but
basically the idea is if you're an
octopus with an array of slot machines
that you're playing and they all payout
rates which you don't know how do you
prioritize which arms to pull so that
you can learn their value but also
profit from at the same time so this is
sort of it's kind of like boils down to
the the core of what reinforcement
learning is about we're in the sense
that you have this exploration versus
exploitation trade-off that is a result
of not having a supervisor right you
have to collect your own data in order
to develop your own policy and this is
most commonly applied in in adtech I
would say so instead of being an
optimist at a slot machine you can be an
advertiser with a set of ads that you
can show to a customer and you want to
maximize the chance that they click on
that ad right I've said most of this
already I think the main thing I just
want to stress here is that tests
needing to balance testing and
exploitation it it is often framed in
advertising context but it can be much
more general than that like real life is
not all cowgirl competitions often you
don't have data for the market that you
want to move into and you do think
carefully about how to test efficiently
and this can help you do that okay so
real quick my favorite way my favorite a
way of doing a sort of simple idealized
bandit it was called Thompson sampling
so the way this works is if you think of
theta as your click rate for a given ad
then you can write down
using a Bayes rule what you really care
about is the probability distribution of
theta given your data and we can model
that as a beta distribution right or why
is the number of clicks we've seen and n
is the number of impressions we have
done so far so what you do is you have
you have a distribution like this for
each add and when you need to make a
decision you just sample a random number
for each distribution and then serve
sort them and serve the one with the
highest number and what that's going to
end up doing is the more sort of skewed
to the higher click rate your
distribution is the more likely it is to
win so you'll be more likely to serve
ads that you think are the best but if
you have an ad that you just don't know
anything about it will have a broad
distribution and it will still get
chosen sometimes and that's how you can
balance text testing and exploiting so
can we play this video so this this will
demonstrate more clearly so initially we
don't know anything about these
distributions and then what happens as
we as we show our ads quickly we start
to gain confidence that this is the best
ad and because of that we'll be showing
it more often right and that's why its
distribution becomes more and more
narrow because it's being tested more
and more often which is a good thing
actually because we know very little
about the exact click rate of this bad
ad but we know enough to have a good
degree of confidence that it's not
better than the other two okay so as
opposed to just like traditional split
testing you basically don't waste your
tests on things that are unlikely to be
the best okay the other good thing about
this is that if things are dynamic it
can you don't need to you can automate
this much more easily and not have to
rerun multiple comparisons okay all
right this will be my last slide since
we're running out of time I mentioned
this a little bit earlier but this is
the thing this is what I've recently
become most interested in this is this
is a fun topic as gaining a lot of
attention deep reinforcement learning so
as I said before these policy gradient
methods are really
citing and a lot of the Outlands you'll
see on open AI are are using these
techniques so this is a challenge where
this simulated person is trying to stand
up as quickly as possible and it's
trying to learn a policy for doing that
so I just kind of like watching it but
you can see it's kind of funny because
it's not a real human it it learns
strange policies it kind of likes to
spread its legs out and then sleep them
together to stand up but anyway so what
what this is doing is if if pie is your
policy so basically this is like this is
some function that will output a score
for each action given the state you're
in and a set of model parameters theta
right and our goal is to find theta that
maximizes your expected rewards given
your policy okay expected total rewards
given your policy that's our challenge
so basically what it turns out what it
turns out to be the case is if you
choose a sensible parametrized policy
where you can compute gradients of this
expectation then you can efficiently
using gradient descent find that maximum
and what is often done is this policy is
a neural net and these parameters theta
are the weights in that neuron that okay
and so that's what's that's what's going
on here that's okay and I guess all one
more shout out again I don't have any
affiliation with these guys I just think
it's a really good resource so I
recommend checking that out